all right one last topic before we go
and and this one is bizarre to me last
week there was a san diego jury that was
looking into the question of whether or
not kellen winslow had committed
multiple rapes now a different san diego
jury taking up this fraud case brought
by drew brees against a jeweler who sold
brees a bunch of investment grade
diamonds that ended up being not worth
nearly as much as what brees paid for
them a jury will begin deliberating
today and chris here's my question for
you because i'm still not sure whether
or not the guy delivered diamonds
different than the ones that brees
thought he was buying or whether
brees just paid too much for the
diamonds because he didn't bother to get
him appraised before he bought them but
what kind of what kind of a blow is this
to a guy's overall image in the locker
room if he's admitting to the world he
got screwed out of 6.7 million dollars
because he he rushed into a purchase of
diamonds well they're all going to go
damn you got a lot of money to buy six
point seven million dollar diamonds
that's the first thing he's gonna hear
from damn you got that ice huh you got
jewelry uh you can't hide money right
you can't hide money so he's gonna get a
lot of that certainly he won't be the
first player in an nfl locker room to
get ripped off by in some shape or form
by jewelry or somebody selling jewelry
happened to me in my career i'll tell
you that right off the bat bought a
really expensive watch mic you know got
it from through another major players
through another no not money players
money money players they were stand up
people i i never worried about them but
i got a watch through a friend on the
team who had a jeweler and the guy was
in town and oh hey come over and he's
got some watches and i got the watch and
you know i paid a lot of money for it
and the watch has never worked correctly
and i i had never seen the guy again i
know he wasn't from and i wasn't going
to start a lawsuit and stuff like that
but that's what happens they take they
prey on players at times oh i'll come
into town they don't really know me uh i
got 20 of these watches one of them
doesn't work right i'm going to sell it
to one of these guys they'll pay they
won't ask any questions and i'll be out
of the state by the time they realize
what's wrong i don't know what happened
here this is a weird thing to me i mean
i don't know players that invest like
what does investment grade diamonds even
mean i have no idea i didn't know that
you invested in jewelry and here's the
thing about jewelry jewelry has a
ridiculous markup anyway i mean i want
to be damn sure before i pay for that
kind of an item i wanted to be
independently appraised so i know what
i'm getting and i don't know how it
appreciates in value or doesn't all i
know is when you buy jewelry there's a
pretty good chance you're going to get
screwed there's a pretty good chance
you're going to pay too much because
they always make you pay too much yes
you're right exactly right it's like a
car or anything like that i mean it it's
worse it is the markup on jewelry is
obscene chris let me tell you this story
yeah my i told this on radio earlier my
mom never bought anything for herself
one thing she bought for herself was a
diamond tennis bracelet it was like 250
bucks and that was a big big deal that's
a huge expenditure for mom to make so
she loved that thing she wore it all the
time before she died she gave it to my
wife and a couple months after my mom
passed christmas was coming and i wanted
to find a necklace that matched it the
same style the same shape the same
everything so i find this necklace this
is great and they tell me it's 90 off
and they're like isn't this great it's
90 off i said people
i'm never going to buy anything here at
the full price what are you doing you
can sell this thing at 90 off and still
make money my god how much are you
charging for this crowd so yeah that's
just that's the nature of the jewelry
industry and i don't know what the hell
drew was thinking and this is a guy who
always wins and i wonder how much of
this lawsuit is just you know it's a bad
business deal and maybe there was no
violation of the law involved chris but
this is drew brees and drew brees wins
and drew brees is going to win and this
is his way of doing it i'm going to take
you to court and i'm going to sue you
because it can't be that i made a
mistake it can't be that i lost because
that's how intensely competitive he is
well it also sounds like there was like
a personal
relationship just from the things i've
read too right where i mean i know the
guy is denying it but drew brees is kind
of trying to say that the guy was like a
friend and a family friend i don't think
drew brees would make those accusations
honestly i don't think he would just
bullcrap us through that kind of
statement i really don't i have a hard
time believing that no but i'm saying
but i'm saying at some level he's driven
to do this yeah okay sure he's driven to
show that he was right and and yeah he
may feel at a certain level that he was
preyed upon by a guy he thought was a
friend right there is that element there
and uh you know he may have gotten duped
the question is
does that cross the line into a legal
violation the jury is going to determine
it but uh one thing
one of my rules is don't do any business
deals with anybody in the jewelry
business or anybody that owns oil
there's an oil tycoon history has shown
us that they're
there's they can be yeah dirty business
dealings type of people i mean there's a
reason there's movies like that about
those kind of people and they're never
like oh look at this great samaritan
this oil tycoon it's usually like no
look at all the people's lives he ruined
to get the oil or all the people that
that this people have you know underpaid
or put to work to get the diamonds so
they're dirty industries and that's
where i just look at drew brees going i
mean you know what'd you expect i didn't
expect this guy to be a choir boy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports